a Brit and an American swap countries to
try each other's McDonald's this is food
Wars
we'll start with some things you can't
find in the UK but I think might be
slightly different over here let's start
with the iconic McDonald's Big Mac so I
mean visually looks pretty much the same
you got the quite sad flimsy beef
patties let's give it a try
I think there are some subtle
differences there actually like broadly
speaking if you gave it to me and we're
like this is a UK Big Mac I don't think
I would doubt you I think it's the
source because the UK Big Mac sauce
it's got like quite a Tang to it almost
and this is very gentle I barely get
anything from it the Big Mac now this
looks exactly like a Big Mac anywhere in
the world you know what I gotta do
I asked give this a shot
if that isn't exactly the same it's
close I mean if I could do one side by
side I probably notice but
I remember when we did fast food
chemistry you guys like had more
chemicals and stuff to use but I'm here
to say the chemicals have not made a
striking difference uh it tastes almost
exactly the same then we're into the
fries and the coke aspect of the meal
firstly I have to point out how enormous
these are the size of this drink is
ridiculous this is way bigger than
almost any fast food drink I've seen in
the UK ever even the fries as well like
this box of fries is used they're kind
of like sunk down a little bit so it
doesn't really show how full it was but
like this carton is massive you can fit
so many fries in it it feels like almost
double the size of a carton of UK fries
I mean these are pretty good I will say
I think they've held up a lot better
after like a bit of time out of the
fryer than UK fries have UK McDonald's
fries I think maybe because they don't
have as many ingredients there aren't
the kind of like preservative chemicals
in there they don't really hold up very
well at all as soon as they come out the
fryer they kind of just get worse and
worse and worse so you have to eat them
really like while they're hot I think
taste wise there are some slight
differences as well there is like
something more than just kind of like
salt going on here
so I only know this because we made that
fast food chemistry episode of
McDonald's fries
but there is like a sort of artificial
beef flavor that's added to these and
you do kind of taste it it's very subtle
but there's like a kind of like Savory
depth of flavor to these that you just
don't get in the UK
I kind of like it I can't lie I first
think about these fries these guys are
pale looking not the bright yellow I'm
used to in the states the whole thing is
this this is potato salt and oil that's
it
yeah
and I believe it because these are bland
man
what no on the fries USA ones are way
better and then finally this enormous
McDonald's Coke
I don't know what it is about McDonald's
Coke but it just always hits different
that happens in the UK and yeah kind of
still happens here another iconic menu
item that I thought was worth trying was
McNuggets so just visually speaking
before I even try it these look quite
different to British McNuggets I'm
fairly sure the ones in the UK are deep
fried correct me if I'm wrong editor but
these ones look almost more deep fried
somehow just in terms of the way that
the breading has kind of like puffed up
and blistered a little bit I also I
think the breading maybe has slightly
more seasoning a bit more flavor going
on here than I'm used to the chicken
itself I think is pretty much the same I
think I might prefer British nuggets
sorry guys nuggets look like almost
exactly the same size
smell the same
same amount of crispness on the skin
no much blander much blander you guys
are getting you guys are getting a
terrible deal with these nuggets because
this is dry I didn't know this is 100
chicken breast meat on this one I do not
know if that's the case in America can
we get that on screen
but I've just been informed no of the
chicken that they use 100 of it is
chicken breast Meats but it's only 45
chicken right it says 100 chicken breast
on it that the implication there is that
the chicken is 100 chicken or it's 100
chicken meat it is not deceptive the
last thing we wanted to compare in both
countries was the mcrispie
here is an American mcrispie it looks
fairly similar to ours on the surface
this one I think is a potato roll rather
than kind of the more like pretzly
brioche version that you find in the UK
there's no sauce
it's just pickles
and a fried chicken patty I really like
the pickles I think pickles and fried
chicken is a great combination and it's
not super common in the UK I will say I
think it needs a sauce I think
technically they claim that they butter
the rolls and that butter is I guess
there for the sauce
but like it's it's kind of dry the
chicken's just like a little bit thin as
well I feel like they look crispy in the
UK tends to be like a thicker and
slightly juicier piece of chicken
this is like a fairly thin
and quite dry chicken breast and a
crispy
oh nice all right I'm pleasantly
surprised by the bun like reminds me
like King's Hawaiian rolls yeah this
looks like our McChicken it is so close
to the McChicken better bun
then the McChicken but the crispiness of
the chicken patty it tastes slightly
different I would say to make chicken
sauce as I hate to say it is a bit
sweeter but because I love the McChicken
like the taste of that is like in My DNA
here are all the US menu items you won't
find at a UK McDonald's here's all the
UK McDonald's menu items I can't get in
the U.S we'll start with some chicken
options namely the deluxe mcrispie and
the spicy deluxe look crispy let's take
a look at the deluxe mcrispie and see
what exactly they're adding to make it
Deluxe the roll looks pretty much the
same as the standard version the chicken
looks the same but I think when they say
Deluxe that just means they've added
mayo lettuce and tomato I don't know if
that is enough to qualify something as
Deluxe doesn't seem Super Deluxe to me I
also think that tomato is just a bad
topping for a burger they've kind of
made this worse in my opinion I'm gonna
take a bite of the spicy one and see if
it's good and if it's spicy and does
have some heat to it they won't get them
for my measly British person palette I
think I would probably just buy the
regular version of them at crispy and
then like add some sauce to it so you
got a bacon Mayo chicken and a Mayo with
mayo chicken no this might be exactly
what the McChickens like I'm nah it's a
little wimpier yeah this is like since
we're talking about like it's a big
McNugget
the Mayo's weird because we're like
stale aftertaste I'm telling you your
guys's breaded chicken at McDonald's has
no flavor compared to one in the U.S uh
then a crispy was crispier had more
flavor in the sauce and the bun was
nicer yeah this is like a it's a bummer
uh the same with bacon but I really have
to no no like flimsy your bacon is now
works with some beef options starting
with the McDouble I have just some kind
of like existential questions about the
McDouble namely why does it exist
because we have the double cheeseburger
give it a try I'm genuinely curious like
how is this different to just a double
cheeseburger slice of cheese one slice
of cheese Joe says one slice of cheese
talk me through it okay so what's going
on here is that the the McDouble has one
slice of cheese in between we're a
double cheese we have two slices of
cheese oh I think that's the only
difference I honestly think it's right
because this is just like the standard
yeah this looks very normal there's just
one less slice of cheese from what we
can tell and the price difference is
let's get that on screen uh so if you
want to save that amount of money get
yourself a McDouble
and uh the past the savings on to you
there you go cheers Joe you had it here
first next up we have the quarter
pounder with cheese deluxe so similarly
to the MC crispy they've turned this
thing into a deluxe burger by just
adding some lettuce some mayo and some
tomato you know what they've tried to do
here they've tried to just make a
Whopper this is the double quarter
pounder with bacon
now this is a burger
this one does what you would expect a
quarter Panda to do
it's just loads of meat and cheese
I want to talk more about this bacon as
well because this Bacon's good one thing
that I think we do quite badly in the UK
at fast food is bacon a lot of the bacon
you'll find on UK restaurants uh is like
this very pallid pink color whereas this
one stronger flavor you get some like
smokiness from it the bacon on this is
way better and therefore that makes it a
very enjoyable Burger yes I think the
deluxe should just be more beef and some
bacon rather than vegetables that no one
wants to eat come on
yeah now we're talking two patties
although I'm telling you guys the Patty
on Patty with nothing in the middle it's
just weird a poppy sesame seed bun
hybrid
whoa yeah it doesn't look barbecue sauce
like barbecue sauce like an Amber Brown
it's like the bacon kind of screws it up
because your bacon is so flimsy I think
this would work with like American bangs
American bacon which is like
crisp I mean it's not like it has a bit
crispier it's just this is like really
like rubbery what do you guys think
barbecue sauce is
bacon double cheeseburger I'm not
impressed with your bacon here guys I'm
not improv look at
yeah like I'm pretty sure we had a bacon
double cheeseburger at some point in
McDonald's and it wasn't like this our
bacon is like crispier more dispersed
evenly I guess it's like two strips
going right through the middle here
that's a disaster the total disaster
Nick plant Harry get in here and explain
to me what I'm doing what what this is
uh this is the mcpart it's McDonald's
fake meat Burger it took them ages to
develop this they tested it in
Scandinavia first it was available in
Sweden for a while they also developed
their own vegan cheese because
McDonald's couldn't find a commercial
vegan cheese that I thought was good
enough yeah I believe it look at this
this looks terrifying buddy thanks bud
what he said I think it was only
available in a few places in the U.S
came and went
so at least the US audience not
impressed with the mcplant
yeah I'm not going there's definitely
some plant-based meat that tastes good
that tastes like meat this ain't it I
want to take this moment to try your UK
Coca-Cola
man the coke here is way better you guys
make with the real sugar
off with this does this and these are
the dippers right
who do you think you are McDonald's who
do you think you are doing this you just
took the difference
oh God gross what is this like what is
this
vegetables
yo this sucks ass dude yeah the
vegetarian says he loves him put an
asterisk next to that of all the things
you can eat at McDonald's there's two
right and this is one of them so okay
great I never want this
moving on ah chicken selects this is
closer to like what our McChicken and
our nuggets taste like
oh yeah damn which made us in America
the sour cream and chive dip is really
good here are all the exclusive wraps
and salads that you can find in the US
that you won't find in the UK that's not
a mistake there are just none of them
it's not even that there's no exclusives
there's just no wraps or salads Full
Stop on a U.S McDonald's menu
shade I can't exactly say that the UK
salads are good at McDonald's but at
least we have them you know you have an
option if you somehow are trying to eat
healthy but have ended up in a
McDonald's anyway whereas in America the
closest thing you have to a salad is bag
of apple slices oh God
I hate wraps this is a really smart way
of presenting this a pita
is that a pita
oh yeah I guess it's closer to a
tortilla
Peter how you said
no that's wrong this is an eye Peter
well you'd be wrong
well it says garlic Bob
not very garlic okay so then we have the
grilled version of this yeah
no no no no no
what flavor could this possibly have
oh come on
that's a bit of bread no come on oh man
it has no flavor
yeah you can get a grilled or crispy
chicken salad but we didn't get them
because I didn't fly across the planet
to eat a salad hey this is fun nacho
cheese wedges well we're much further
from Mexico
so how good could the nacho cheese
actually be
not bad it's really the most flavorful
thing I've eaten today now it's time for
the exclusive condiments and you know
what that means this is a sauce talk
the very first sauce talk foreign
exchange sauce
we're gonna start with this one spicy
buffalo
yeah so I think that's the same one that
they put on the spicy mcrispie
it's pretty good it's basically like if
you take a mayo and just pour some
Frank's Red Hot in it let's try the
honey mustard out I personally love a
honey mustard
you certainly get the honey it's pretty
good I think the balance of that is more
on the honey side
and it needs to swing slightly more to
the mustard side now this one I'm
excited for it's Ranch we call it Ranch
not Ranch
yeah that's pretty good yeah it's got
like a sort of Herby Tang to it then
we've got a couple of condiments which
are technically breakfast items but
we're going to count under Source talk
anyway we'll start with the mild Picante
salsa I think this is supposed to be
paired with the uh breakfast burrito
which we will get on to later but I'm
going to try it with a nugget
laughs
okay that's enough
that's what it says on the tin I'd say
I'm just a mild sauce already also on
the breakfast condoms list we have hot
cake syrup
I guess like maybe legally they're not
allowed to call it maple syrup so hot
cake syrup
I mean like people eat pancakes with
bacon and maple syrup so why can't
chicken nuggets and maple syrup grow
together
okay I thought I thought I'd invented
something special there but
that turns out I cannot claim that
combination as my own it's butter they
have butter on the menu I think again
designed to be used with the hot cakes
the final condiment option is some grape
Jam
I will say like we don't tend to have
many grape flavored products in the UK
for whatever reason
yeah
they're pretty tasty yeah I mean like
maybe not in combination with the
chicken but the grape Jam is quite nice
alrighty your ketchup it's bizarre it
makes sense
why this would be ketchup considering
what ketchup is but American ketchup is
way sweeter I don't know if it's a good
thing or bad thing but like I'm eating
that and I'm like
if that was on a plate I was eating
someone that was on a plate and I was
like dipping into it I'd be like oh what
sauce is this because I wouldn't think
that's ketchup like oh it's like this
fun like tomato sauce you guys like I
wouldn't go oh ketchup yeah it's like
that different okay the barbecue sauce
from the country with no barbecue
let's see what you got let's see what
you guys think barbecue is nope I don't
know what this is supposed to be sweet
chili dip here we go better
just okay McDonald's barbecue sauce is
its own special brand of barbecue sauce
yeah this is pretty close to a bug
this one has a little this one's a
little more mustardy
so okay yeah it's not bad
all right sweet and sour ooh that's
really good oh hell yeah dude sweet
Curry been waiting for this that's
really good we don't have any exclusive
options when it comes to the food inside
a Happy Meal but I did want to get one
and just kind of like see what the vibe
was see what the toy is crucially
so at the time of recording this uh The
Little Mermaid photos recently so they
seem to be doing a collab with the
little mermaid
does that mean I'm gonna get a Little
Mermaid toy let's find out
so we go oh these fries are so cute so
this is a UK large
this is what I'm used to I'm also in the
UK the fries come in like a paper bag
rather than one of these Simply Adorable
little uh cartons which honestly huge
fan of I went for the McNuggets which
tend to come in a box of four
there you go you get the apple slices
within that this is the American salad
and of course we get a toy oh it's King
Triton let's go place your toy on a
phone or tablet for more fun
which I do think we have to try and do
real quick okay put it down put my phone
on the on the desk yeah you guys are
getting the table getting all this this
is this is crucial
take a thing I'll just go there okay
Play It Again turn your sound on
I'm gonna be honest this is uh this is a
mess some kind of pattern learn pattern
that one that one
did it I win DC Happy Meal
I've been told that it's let's look at
the toy oh poison ivy fast food fish is
way more popular here you guys love your
fast fish I do not
smells fishy
for the first time your food being
flavorless is a good time fries yeah
this is actually I would say this is
also our kid's size let's take a look at
the poison ivy to it what's that what
okay oh there's some inside
stickers
the game all right fun for kids
now we're into some Cafe and dessert
options unfortunately I couldn't get a
few of these but here are the ones that
I was able to find today we'll start
with a good old-fashioned American
chocolate chip cookie this looks pretty
good we're kind of bad at cookies in the
UK I don't know what it is but they tend
to be very like dry and crumbly rather
than soft and chewy
that's not bad what's more American than
apple pie I'll tell you what an apple
pie from McDonald's
this is the American McDonald's apple
pie in the UK a McDonald's apple pie is
actually deep fried it just looks very
different this is a baked apple pie so
you get more of like a lattice going on
you see the filling there but it's baked
so I guess you know they don't need to
seal it on every side because it's not
going in a fryer it's not going to spill
out into the oil I don't know if it's
going to hold up or not
I think the UK might be doing better
apple pies than the US's at least when
it comes to McDonald's the pastry is
fine
the filling tastes pretty much identical
to the filling of a UK apple pie
but yeah like the baked pastry is just
not the same as fried pastry and then
there's actually another pie option on
the menu right now at a US McDonald's
this one is a strawberry cream pie
not pretty good as I said there were
some desserts and pastries that we
weren't able to get today here they are
in the UK you can also get exclusive
McFlurries could not get them because
you're not going to believe it but the
ice cream machines are also broken in
the UK you can get yourself a maltesers
McFlurry and a smarties McFlurry okay we
got them the cafe snacks
first up oh a donut hey it doesn't like
a donut oh yo this one is covered in
Sugar look at that muffin Berry
muffin a Millionaire's donut huh
with the with the cream inside it is
pretty decadent I don't know if I feel
like a millionaire I don't think
Millionaire's reading those I'm gonna be
honest with you
oh hell yeah
yeah yup that's a good cookie let's talk
about the drinks first of all there are
some hot and cold coffees which are
available in both countries it does seem
like the US actually has a bigger range
of coffees particularly when it comes to
the iced versions while in the UK we're
limited to a couple of basic ones like
an ice latte over here you can get all
sorts you can get things like your iced
caramel mocha your frappa mocha Chino
Duncan thingy majiggy you know the ones
there are some interesting non-coffee
drinks though that I do want to try and
talk about now we'll start with this one
down the end which I believe is Hawaiian
Punch
not common in the UK at all
yeah okay
uh if this is the first one I think I
have a bit of a storm coming here it's
pretty good but wow is that sweet this
one is an American style lemonade as
I've said before on the show lemonade in
the UK is like Sprite it's like a clear
carbonated lemony beverage whereas this
looks like a good old-fashioned American
lemonade
it's not bad it's weird like to me that
lemonade isn't carbonated but that's
pretty good that's actually fairly
refreshing unlike maybe the Hawaiian
Punch was also uh Happy Birthday Grimace
while we're on the subject they did have
a special Grimace Shake but the ice
cream machine was broken at the
McDonald's that we went to of course so
I haven't been able to get the Grimace
show which I'm really sad about here's
what it's supposed to look like
they do not have a good old-fashioned
cup of tea on the menu at an American
McDonald's what they do have is sweet
tea I felt like I had to try it as a
Brit you know I have to give my thoughts
on everyone's teas
no they weren't kidding when they called
it sweet tea
um so this was supposed to be a blue
raspberry frozen Fanta and this was
supposed to be a frozen Coke however now
it is just a melted blue raspberry Fanta
and a melted Coke otherwise known as
Coke
oh
that's pretty good
just Taste of coke it does somehow like
still has a bit of Fizz to it and the
same with the Fanta actually I do think
I would like these if they were frozen I
think like on a really hot day for
example carrying a frozen Coke around
sounds delightful so yeah uh would quite
like those on the UK menu maybe then we
have a what I believe to be high C drink
high C orange lava burst yeah so this
isn't carbonated but it's not fruit
juice it's somewhere in the middle
I put it like reasonably close to an
oasis that we can get in the UK which is
also like a sort of non-carbonated
fruity beverage I don't love it last but
by no means least we have milk on the
menu I think this is kind of aimed at
kids I never want to meet a person who
is a grown adult and goes to McDonald's
and orders milk with their meal these
are all the exclusive drinks we got
today there are some other ones and here
they are the McCafe exclusives uh they
didn't label any of them so I'll just
guess that's definitely hot chocolate
but let's see what it causes it compared
to the deluxe
um
oh this is the butter thing that's
terrible we'll get back to that let me
find the other hot chocolate
that's a hot chocolate
I can't tell the difference I don't know
which ones would Deluxe be size
wait this one has like that buttery oil
floating in it and this
I know what this is
tea
don't get it I don't get why this is so
popular then the cafe food's pretty good
I like it you got a good selection here
the drinks not so much I like banana I
like banana flavored stuff and we don't
nearly have as much in the United States
this tastes exactly like a banana Laffy
Taffy it's great what's Oasis
yeah no thanks
no thanks and it's like sweet but it
like reminds me like Gatorade
um orange juice I know what orange juice
tastes like what is this Robinson's
fruit shoot why is it a Fruit Shoot
what's the shooting part
oh so this is like shoot in my mouth
then what
I would like to know why this is called
Fruit Shoot okay so I think it's called
I've been looked at I think it's called
fruit shoe because I want you to squeeze
like shooting your mouth yeah
uh and Leon thinks it's because it
sounds better than saying Coke now we're
going to talk about the most important
meal of the day breakfast we'll start
with this one the steak and egg McMuffin
that doesn't really look taste or feel
like a steak now next up America has
some breakfast biscuit options so from
what I've seen a biscuit looks very much
like a scone which is obviously a
classic British dish now the fact that
they would be putting breakfast food
like bacon eggs sausages into what is
effectively a scone is weird to me and I
think will be weird to a lot of Brits as
well so this is just a classic sausage
biscuit it looks does look pretty like a
scone it's maybe a bit more like Smooth
on the outside than I'm expecting from a
scone
food Wars here I just wanted to say
that's not a scone it's a different
biscuit I don't know what he's talking
about he'll be chewing on that for the
next four minutes but it's different
he's right it's different it's not a
scum it's somehow worse yeah apparently
I chose badly with the sausage being my
first one because that was dry as a
desert so let's have a quick bite of a
bacon egg and cheese which is a classic
American slash New York breakfast combo
they're still pretty dry but the
addition of the other stuff definitely
helps one of the takeaways there
um scones and biscuits are different not
the same it's gone is a little bit more
crumbly generally like slightly sweeter
these are not sweet slightly more bready
texture
I'm still not convinced by the notion of
them as like the foundation of a
breakfast sandwich just mostly because
of how dry they are but hey who am I to
uh judge American culture now these I'm
excited for I've heard very good things
about these from Joe these are
McDonald's McGriddles if I remember
correctly from watching Joey these
they've kind of got like pancakes that
they sort of inject with syrup and then
use those as the buns for a breakfast
sandwich which sounds pretty excellent
I'll try the bacon egg and cheese see
how we get them
still slightly dry but way less driving
the biscuit and very tasty I'm gonna go
even more syrup because what's better
than adding more syrup to something
which is already full of syrup
McGriddles yes
biscuits
not so sure so this was the bacon egg
and cheese McGriddle you can also get
McGriddles with sausage sausage and egg
and cheese or the steak which I will not
be trying the next exclusive breakfast
item is the bacon egg and cheese
breakfast bagel we used to have Bagels
on the menu at the UK McDonald's and
they were wonderful
part of the breakfast menu toasted
bagels with your choice of toppings and
fillings really good pandemic hit they
cut them from the menu and they've not
returned and personally I'm furious
about that
yeah they've missed you so much Bagel
next up we have a sausage burrito
breakfast burrito is really not a thing
in the UK
we're just like generally bad at Mexican
food this is obviously designed to be
enjoyed with the mild salsa it's
actually pretty good and then lastly on
the breakfast menu we have these the big
breakfasts the standard big breakfast is
a slab of scrambled egg
a sausage patty and a biscuit and this
is the big breakfast with hot cakes
which is the egg biscuit and sausage but
then also comes with two pancakes both
of these come with dips including a
little thing of whipped butter and of
course the hot cake syrup so I wasn't
sure what the difference was between
pancakes and Hot Cakes Josh has done a
quick Google and apparently Hot Cakes
tend to be a bit thicker and denser than
pancakes I mean to me that just tastes
like a pancake I'm thinking maybe
they've just called hot them hotcakes to
make them sound more fancy or different
but yeah not bad and of course
McDonald's UK I gotta try the breakfast
all right first up the mini potato
waffles hash browns are shaped like a
waffle I don't know why this specific
shape
oh
yeah dude for some reason it tastes a
lot better in Waffle form I don't know
why that is it is really good what do
you got here breakfast sandwich
this is the bacon roll with brown sauce
a burger bun
look at this
there's your brown sauce right there
it's just okay nothing special
it's a bland
I'm starting to I'm starting to think
that you in the UK you guys don't like
your stuff isn't as like intense as ours
in America is like this wouldn't fly in
the U.S
because it's not dripping with cheese
and it doesn't have an egg in it and the
Buns aren't like uber buttery is this
too plain it's too boring this is the
same thing with just ketchup
oh
now we're getting more my speed
this one has cheese and bacon in it oh
yeah is that sausage
yeah this looks more like something
they'd get in the U.S
yeah
cheesy flatbread oh God
cheesy come on guys yeah see this is the
bacon this is more like the bacon we're
used to so that's
streaky bacon so this is bacon and the
other thing was Canadian bacon in the
U.S
I don't know why or or ham I'm gonna
call it I mean this just looks like I
mean this looks like whatever
yes sir and that's why it sucks it's
like the the flatbread is too strong I
can barely taste the streaky bacon which
is the weather came here for so double
sausage okay so with this you guys just
went double meat on both
yeah this now we're talking UK see
although nothing in between the two
sausage patties is like you gotta like
it's Gotta Go cheese meat cheese meat
you can't just do meat this like this
this doesn't work and possibly like a
sauce no sauce is weird for this one
your sausage is weird I would say ours
is like spicier not heat but like the
flavor of the sausage is more pronounced
in the US One compared to this so I know
in the US our sausage is made up of
and from what I understand the UK
sausage is made up of
and that was all done in post I have no
idea what it says I I do like seriously
thing I like the double but needs more
cheese needs to be drowning in some sort
of sauce but this one I'm assuming that
is
uh double bacon
I don't know this is not double bacon
wait skip one two pieces of Bacon's
double bacon
this is double for you guys for real yo
you're getting ripped off guys excuse me
you've made a mistake I'm like to come
back and like I'm like storming and
cutting the line be like ah you made a
mistake on mine there's only one slice
of bacon on this so all right let's try
let's try with this double bacon
I mean it's ham
yeah that's standard that's not
that's not double this is smart that
they did the I don't know if they in the
US they have the squirtable one I mean
do I need to like I mean I know what a
muffin and jam tastes like I'm not like
if I eat this will I still have had a
British muff in a gym
I think after this I still have no idea
what a British muffin and jam tastes
like all right all right all right all
right everyone relax
oh yeah it's really good
this tastes way better than the crap
that we have like way better sorry I've
just been informed that in England these
are just called muffins not English
muffins porridge
I'm from the US I don't know what
porridge is I'm assuming it's oatmeal
so from what I can tell you can porch
four different ways one with golden
syrup looks a lot like honey one with
strawberry jam straight from France one
with uh sugar which they did not include
and then one plain so first I'm just
going
straight porridge No Chaser yeah there's
no flavor to it
yeah all right so I've been informed
that golden syrup is good stuff
I don't know what's interesting golden
syrup but I guess whatever other syrups
you're right it's like it's not quite
maple syrup but it's pretty close
makes it much better obviously
all right overall area of the American
exclusives what were some of your likes
and some of your dislikes
some of the things I liked uh you guys
have a much bigger breakfast menu than
we do I did like them at griddles they
did live up to uh Joe's pretty high
billing
I also think that your bacon is much
better than ours so I think maybe the
double quarter pounder with bacon was uh
was a strong highlight there
some dislikes
um
there's a few I don't like the biscuits
I'm sorry guys I think they are like for
a British person too similar to a scone
so we can't really like mentally
differentiate between the two and it's
just quite dry
um and also I think like making your
Burgers Deluxe by just adding loads of
mayo some tomato and lettuce just is a
bit underwhelming not really a deluxe
Vibe for me one thing to the UK from the
US exclusive what would it be if I could
take one of these exclusives that I've
tried today back to the UK with me for
our menu I think I'm gonna have to pick
the bacon egg and cheese McGriddle I
think it was really good it's a bit of a
Twist on the classic muffin formula
feels like a little bit more decadent
maybe a little bit more sweet
um and yeah just uh really good fun I
like the emphasis you guys place on your
breakfast menu
but the thing that I hated the most and
would want to remove from all possible
menus
It's Tricky there were there were a
couple
but I think it might have to be the
sausage biscuit it was so dry and the
notion of a biscuit slash scone
breakfast sandwich to a British person
is just too bizarre I can't get mad
around it and uh yeah not the best now
yeah I really disliked your bacon your
bacon is weird
it ruined everything that I was on I
love bacon but your bacon is just it is
bizarre the things I like the most I
obviously like the curry dipping sauce I
like the banana milkshake separately
obviously that that triple chocolate
chip cookie was good
uh I'm taking back the the curry dipping
sauce I wanted to try that since we shot
the first episode
um and then
take off your menu
I mean those veggie Dippers were pretty
dismal but I don't want to leave
vegetarians out in the lurch
the thing that's like haunting me the
most was the grilled chicken wrap I
don't think it was grilled I think it
was boiled and uh I feel bad that that's
on your menu and it's gross and I will I
will do the UK favor all grilled chicken
off the menu McDonald's you're welcome
a Brit and an American swap countries to
try each other's KFC this is food Wars
[Music]
we're gonna start with some things you
can get in both the US and the UK to see
if there are some subtle differences in
taste or anything else the first thing
for me to try the main event the Fried
Chicken so there's just original recipe
chicken I've got what looks to be a
thigh piece visually I think it probably
looks slightly more appealing than
British fried chicken from KFC tends to
look the breading is like all over the
place there's no bare patches here I
always struggle to like identify where
the bones are in pieces of KFC I don't
want to just bite straight into a bone
okay yeah this is good compared to the
UK I think I definitely am getting more
flavor I think a fair amount of that is
coming from the breading it's actual
seasoning and flavor
it was like a thick juicy piece of
chicken I don't want to go back to
eating regular British KFC after this
right the six piece bucket this looks
like it has more skin than what we got
in the restaurant I will say strawberry
this looks like it has a Better Batter
to it
that is so Bland so I can taste the
flavors and I was like strong and I'm
assuming that's the chemicals we put in
our food to make it taste like yes the
next thing we wanted to compare was
popcorn chicken which I think in the UK
is a pretty iconic menu item although
weirdly enough they've actually cut it
from the menu in the U.S right now the
exception being that they will still add
it to famous bowls but we'll get to that
later so I guess for the time being I
will try a U.S chicken nugget and see
how that compares I mean like this just
kind of looks like popcorn chicken
definitely a bit more dry on the palette
again I don't see why they've got rid of
popcorn chicken in lieu of these because
popcorn chicken is effectively the same
thing it's like a shot
whoa how awesome well I don't taste
anything so far I would say that KFC
chicken both on the bone and popcorn in
the U.S the flavor is more pronounced
and has more of like a Savory flavor to
it this flavor has training wheels
I'm there
foreign
there are some twists on the classic
Fried Chicken which we can't usually
find the first variety we have here is
the spicy fried chicken I mean like
visually this looks fairly similar to
just the sort of standard original
recipe although I will say the uh the
breading looks pretty good you get a lot
of these little like flakes of breading
which really tend to get crisp and stay
crisp
there's enough to call it spicy because
I'm not like a guy who has a super high
spice tolerance and for me that's like
warm but not much more than that it's
very pleasant and I do think it's
crispier than the original recipe very
juicy flavorful I think this is really
good I think I would be tempted to buy
this over just classic original recipe
and it's not just spicy chicken that's
available in the US you can also get
another type called extra crispy as the
name suggests it's the regular Fried
Chicken but made extra crispy I think
extra crispy should be the KFC chicken
then the original should be like diet
for some reason the branch that we went
to today didn't have it in the form of
regular original recipe chicken but they
did have it in the form of a chicken
little I'm just gonna like break off the
end bit that was Untouched by the Mayo
to see if it is actually crispy or not
I don't think this is extra crispy even
though they told us it was maybe there
are that Chris Bonita was broken today
or something
KFC us is very good at cooking chicken
on the bone that's good when it comes to
cooking chicken off the bone because
this is a little bit dry a little bit
chewy moving on to the snack wrap this
one is the Flaming hat
oh wow this is awesome into it okay okay
yeah that's I like this this is really
good Kansas barbecue okay
the barbecue sauce is pretty good I mean
this is definitely a sweeter sauce which
I think is indicative of Kansas City
Barbecue anyway yeah not bad sweet chili
bites
too sweet not that spicy now we're into
an item which I've been watching from
across the pond with a mixture of horror
and Fascination it's the KFC famous bowl
instead of me trying to explain it I
feel like we should just get Joe in here
Joe do you want to come and explain the
famous bowl to me a little bit of
everything is on the menu just in Bull
form
for anyone who just pretty much given up
on life and still doesn't care as long
as they get in the stomach thanks Joe
you're welcome it's looking more like an
Infamous Bowl right now I'm gonna
it's not horrible there's just a lot
going on there's a lot of flavors
fighting with each other right now vying
for Supremacy the main thing I get I
think is the corn actually I would have
assumed that the mash and the chicken
would have been kind of the stars of the
show but if anything it's everything
else in there that you can actually
taste more
to me it feels a little bit like you're
eating baby food for adults I was gonna
say I'm more excited to try the next
Bowl but I don't know if excited is the
word maybe less anxious to try the next
Bowl this is the KFC mac and cheese Bowl
but the kind of color on that is uh some
course for concern
so I think this actually
Works in harmony with the chicken much
better than the famous bowl does if I
had to get a bowl I think I would be
leaning more towards the mac and cheese
ball down the famous bowl next up is the
KFC pot pie it's funny to see this on
the menu at a KFC in the US because I
feel like meat pies are generally
associated with Britain more we love a
meat pie in the UK steak pie chicken pie
Greg's pucker pies all that good stuff
so we'd like a meat pie in the UK what
you'll often get is the pastry on the
bottom as well so it's like a
self-contained pie whereas I think with
a pot pie you just have a layer of
pastry on top and then filling
underneath and there's no bottom layer
of crust but let's find out
they haven't skimped on the carrot I
taste a lot of the carrot flavor in the
UK for example with a meat pie you tend
to get like a gravy that will kind of
run out when you cut into it but this is
like staying on the spoon it's not like
running off the spoon it's not great but
it's not bad either it's like the sauce
needs a little bit more seasoning I
think it's a little bit Bland a bit more
salt and pepper would not go I missed
that I think with a few minor
adjustments they can make this really
good and I do think Brits would go for
this this is super weird look at that
there's a hash brown that was that what
does that do with like tower that much
hmm I like everything that this is made
of together I don't think it works
supposed to get this I'd ask them to
separate it across three containers and
is he why does it the hash brown then
the chicken finish it off with a slice
of cheese there you go this would be
close to like what our extra crispy is
this is supposed to be a spicy one it's
gonna zing me with spice
[Music]
not bad it's not that I dislike anything
I've had so far
is that it's all 60 to 70 percent as far
as flavor and intensity that I'm used to
in the United States you can also get
yourself a Zinger stacker and a Zinger
Tower Burger yo it is a thick one wow
I'm not gonna bite into this but man
that's a lot this would be right at home
on the U.S menu this would be like yes
of course it's like the double Zinger
and everyone's like yeah of course it's
double
okay vegan burger
kind of looks like chicken
the Mayo pretty much missed it right see
how they how it came so I got to kind of
like activate the Mayo
twist your vegan sandwich before you eat
it it's even ask what the Mayo's made of
I mean we rip it apart it's like one of
those big erasers
I mean I wouldn't just want to eat this
in general but as far as a fake meat
it's pretty close and I don't know why
if you can be like finally a chicken
sandwich at KFC no you can eat this
there's no chicken meat and it's like
yeah but you're still killing them by
the millions so there is a category in
the menu of Twisters rice boxes and
salads they had no rice boxes or salads
they did however have the twisters
but this is called a twister not a wrap
what's Twisted about it what's that
Twisted it looks like they took a
chicken breast and cut it in half and
this was like one long tender
it's also smaller I bet they like wanted
to like appeal to more like male
demographic so don't get a rep get a
twister
a big man I didn't really want to ramble
on Twitter
wraps are for the ladies the dudes have
twisters I don't think that they think
that's KFC shame on you let's talk about
some exclusive sides that you can't find
in the UK firstly if the mac and cheese
bowl is too much mac and cheese for you
you can just get a little cup as a side
you can also get a side of corn you guys
just produce so much of it you can't get
rid of it fast enough uh I'm not trying
corn and like uh here in uh the UK you
guys have corn on the cob obviously ours
is corn off the cob but this would be
easier for driving or like eating on the
go right have you ever seen someone
walking down the streets there's two in
a and a carb on a stick then a stick
you've never seen that keep your eyes
filled I would like to get that Trend
going and of course apparently it
wouldn't be a U.S fast food menu without
biscuits this is an American biscuit it
looks a lot like a British scone at
least on the outside however generally I
think it's a bit more like pretty and
maybe slightly drier than a scone
text to check
it's confusing because with a British
gun they're generally like sweetened
with sugar because they're eaten with
things like jam and cream and it's more
of an afternoon tea slash dessert type
thing whereas these ones are supposed to
be eaten with a Savory meal but actually
smell kind of sweet I think of the
biscuits I've tried from fast food
venues in the US so far this is probably
my favorite one but it's somewhere
between like a British scone and a bread
roll baked beans
well yeah these are way more tomatoey
tomatoey excuse me the tomato sauce and
it's in it's like similar to like
whatever SpaghettiOs come in they will
never be in the mood for that southern
rice
what the hell I don't know what they
think southern is I'm surprised at how
different it is you think an
International Food Chain would want it
to be same everywhere but applying to
the UK tastes I assume KFC in the US has
a bunch of source options that we can't
get in the UK which means it's time for
sauce top for an exchange the theme
seems to be that they have a lot of
Honey on the menu when it comes to their
sauces at KFC in the US the sauce is on
offer here are hot sauce honey sauce a
honey barbecue sauce KFC sauce and yet
more honey a honey mustard I usually
like a honey mustard but I do think you
have to get the balance of honey and
mustard right
yeah that's not bad that's a pretty well
balanced honey mustard I think I'm
intrigued by KFC sauce
I quite like it I really can't put my
finger on exactly what's in it right now
next up we've got the honey barbecue
oh extremely sweet both on the honey
side and even on the kind of barbecue
side let's have a look at the honey
sauce it's fine it does taste pretty
much just like honey and then finally
they have a hot sauce yeah that's pretty
comparable to like a Frank's Red Hot
barbecue
okay Kentucky Smoke Barbecue actually
this is on point sticky sweet chili
sauce why is it sticky
yeah oh that's good all right garlic
buttermilk Mayo I like all three of
those things separately
yeah it's pretty good now let's look at
some exclusive drinks served in these
delightful Diablo branded cups you guys
love a advertisement tie-in day so I
believe this one is Starry Joe's beloved
Sierra Mist unfortunately cold recently
and replaced by Starry let's give it a
try
it's more what I'm used to I guess from
like a UK version of a lemonade style
drink and of course we have a U.S style
lemonade
it's pretty good again to me it's
slightly weird what Americans consider
lemonade considering coming from the UK
lemonade is basically Sprite it's like a
clear carbonated lemony beverage it's
pretty good it's probably like slightly
more refreshing and hydrating than a
Sprite is in the UK there are a couple
of other exclusive drinks which we can
normally get but unfortunately our local
branch did not have devastatingly
because I really wanted to try the
Mountain Dew sweet lightning and regular
American Mountain Dew when we ordered
the bottles of drinks didn't we think it
was just going to be like a a personal
one I don't know the Tango orange seven
up free Pepsi Max Cherry crushums UK of
course is exclusive crushing drinks in
front of me I said give me one of each
and they did milky bar
there's more we're still charging the
same but it's just says you get less in
there so okay less calories by default
because it's all there
I might be the last person to point this
out but like they took the candy bar and
they crushed it and that's why it's
crushings okay Oreo one I mean come on
that's really good I would definitely
get this dessert exclusive desserts get
a white chocolate chip cookie you could
also get a pineapple stick but they
didn't have any at the location we went
to also I don't know what a pineapple
stick is
was that desserts
I think if I could pick one item from
this menu to take back with me to the UK
and put on our menu over there I think
it'd probably be the spicy chicken I
just like how it was slightly more
crispy than the regular chicken and just
added a bit more flavor the level of
heat was really good yeah I think that
would come back with me if I could
remove one thing from the US and all
other menus from KFC I think it would be
the famous bowl I'm sorry guys I don't
want to start some kind of Revolutionary
War again but I just feel like it's not
very good because those ingredients
don't really go together textually it's
a bit of a nightmare and honestly
there's just way better things you can
do with the stuff on the menu I was
really impressed with the the Flamin hat
wrap I made a dog then a little bit
earlier because it was smaller but that
spicy sauce you guys have is actually
pretty good honorable mention the vegan
burger obvious I'm not vegan but I guess
I was surprised by how kind of decent it
was it's not my favorite but I mean
points for it being edible
way to go uh I will do everyone a favor
and I will say I'm not cutting a menu
item let's get that potato off of your
sandwiches they just don't work together
period of Brit and an American swap
countries to try each other's Burger
Kings this is food Wars
so obviously you can get a Whopper meal
at a UK and a US Burger King but we did
want to get them in both countries and
compare the two to see the differences
this year of course is a standard
Whopper meal I believe it was the
regular size and this would be a small
in the U.S just a quick visual check I
mean the Whopper itself looks identical
to the Whopper that I'm used to seeing
in the UK really really no changes there
the toppings seem like to be the same
you get the Mayo the pickles the lettuce
the Tomato onions and of course the beef
on a sesame bun so that's the uh exactly
what I'm used to let's take a look at a
UK Whopper
looks exactly the same so that's good
same size yeah it's a big one right
same stuff on the inside oh like oh I
got a regular one I didn't get it with
cheese
which is rare for me
it tastes pretty similar to what I'm
used to the beef is like pretty similar
if not identical you still get like that
flame grilled thing that Burger King is
kind of known for American Mary so far
has just been very like very creamy but
pretty much everything else is the same
overall very similar to the Whopper that
I'm used to
exactly the same which is good but the
fries however your fries are a bit
different I think honestly the fries
this is a large Whopper meal I was kind
of expecting bigger for the US you know
there's like a good portion of fries
don't get me wrong but I feel like in
the US if you order a large fries I was
expecting like a lot of fries they look
pretty similar to the fries that I'm
used to they're like fairly thick cut
thicker cut than like a McDonald's say
it's a pretty good fries I have to say I
feel like when I go to a Burger King in
the UK I'm not really there for the
fries the fries are just very much just
sort of add on to the meal these are
good these taste way better than the
fries that I'm used to from Burger King
I don't know what they've done
differently they're like quite
aggressively salted which I personally
really like but they're just like well
cooked there's like a little bit of
crisp on the outside
still quite nice and like fluffy on the
inside the US Burger King has the fries
are weird there's some sort of like
batter to them I can't describe it they
changed it years ago and and uh
they're more distinct flavor I don't
dislike them but they're not that great
these are these regular fries I think
like I prefer the UK Burger King fries
over the US once definitely and of
course the fountain Coke I hope that the
camera can capture the scale of just how
large this drink is I have a a big head
yeah I mean it's Fountain Coke it's fine
yes regular drink is so tiny I've just
been informed that a Whopper can be
considered an insult in the UK what does
it mean
that's funny
have you been have you been called the
Whopper before
someone called you a Whopper yeah
I think generally speaking
fairly familiar pretty much what I'm
used to in terms of the burger I've
enjoyed these fries more than I enjoy
the British fries and the coke is too
big dial that back a little bit guys
calm down
here's everything you can get at a BK in
the US that you can't find in the UK
here are the UK Burger King menu items I
cannot get in the US let's take a look
at the U.S beef exclusives we'll start
with this
the Whopper Junior look at this thing
tiny I mean yeah I think it's just a
scaled down version of the Whopper it's
got the same toppings on there then
we're going from one end of the scale
straight to the other we're going from
the junior Whopper
to the triple Whopper as the name
suggests it is a Whopper but instead of
the one patty you get three I mean I
don't necessarily object to the
existence of a triple Whopper I will say
I've got some notes on the assembly
because there's no like layering going
on obviously a Whopper doesn't have
cheese this is literally just like the
toppings and then just three meat
patties back to back
so I feel like when you bite into this
you're just going to get like a big
mouthful of just beef I mean I will try
it for science I'll take a little I'll
take a little bite of the triple
yeah that's kind of confirmed my fears
I'm also covered in mayo next up we're
off to Texas because this is a Texas
whopper in case you're wondering what
made this Texan it seems like they've
just added some jalapenos bacon cheese
and mustard to a standard Whopper I
don't really know enough about Texas
culture to know if that makes something
Texan or not I would have expected maybe
some like barbecue sauce if you caught
up in Texan but they seem to have not
done that so we'll see
I'm a big mustard fan so I like the
inclusion of mustard on this yeah that's
not bad I don't know if I would order
that just over a standard Whopper but I
think it's better than a triple Whopper
this is the BK double melts with a
signature cheesy sauce instead of a slab
of cheese they just drizzled the excuse
me melted liquid cheese the melted
cheese is kind of like a nice texture to
it a slice of cheese but just as easily
suffice bacon double cheeseburger
XL Charlie two patties cheese in the
middle cheese in between them very smart
guys see it makes a difference it's
bigger than in America we have the
regular bacon double cheeseburger this
one is a little bit bigger
no it's extra bitter so there you go
yeah I I like this and I would probably
get this if I went to Burger King I
think this would do really well in
America come on two big beef patties
dripping with cheese and bacon and it's
big it's like its selling point is that
it's big dude this would clean up in the
US if this is in the U.S we gotta get
U.S bacon look at this come on guys look
at this how like nut pink this is
this is like oh this this Bacon's bad
then we have two more Burger exclusives
which are
the kings first up we have the single
quarter pounder King this is a single
quarter pound Patty with some onions
pickles cheese mustard and ketchup this
looks pretty good to me this looks like
a very classic hamburger which I'm kind
of here for I will say in general what
I'm really enjoying about all of these
Burgers is the pickles I feel like
American does pickles way better than we
do
I thought that was going to be better
than it was I don't know why I don't
know what's wrong with it there's like
quite a lot of onion in it it's like a
lot of raw white onion and then the next
one I think we might have had recently
on the menu or might still be on the
menu in the UK but is a bacon King
either way I thought this would be a
good opportunity to talk about fast food
bacon this is a double burger some
cheese in the middle and on top along
with a few rashes of bacon
some ketchup and Mayo let me just prize
a bit of this bacon off this burger
give me a close look
so this
is the famous American fast food bacon
so I feel like the US and the UK do fast
food bacon and I guess bacon in general
pretty differently
this in the UK would be called a streaky
bacon rasher which is where you get the
kind of like thin strips as opposed to
back bacon where you have like a
medallion and then some strip coming off
it generally speaking in the UK fast
food bacon tends to be quite a pallid
pink fairly unappealing color and can be
quite floppy as well they don't have to
cook it basically for long enough I will
say this bacon has a lot more color on
it than I would expect to see from
British fast food bacon
that's pretty good I think that's
probably better than the bacon that I'm
used to from a British fast food chain
so far all the bacon I've had including
this one it just tends to have like a
better texture there's a bit more chew
to it it's just been cooked a little bit
longer I think also lends itself to
giving it a much nicer color and you
definitely get more of like a smoky
flavor from it that you would expect
from good bacon which I don't think you
tend to get from UK fast food bacon yeah
the Gourmet Kings let's go oh fancy
first one Farmhouse straight from the
farm you got your rocket AKA arugula you
got your
pickled red onions in like a smoky
cheddar cheese right this is actually
this is a pretty impressive looking I
gotta say
oh brioche bun
all right here we go
the arugula or rocket kind of ruins it I
like it but um
it's like such a strong flavor it just
really tastes like
arugula rocket whatever it's having a
bite without it it's a lot better so
unfortunately remove a little a little
much this one also has arugula on it so
oh let's get a look in there man they
got the uh we got barbecue sauce crispy
onions right
uh same same cheddar same fun cheddar
the Brewers are going to still a little
overpowering but with the fun stuff and
this cheese is on here is really good
like the smoked cheddar this one's good
I would get this I like this so
Steakhouse over Farmhouse then we have a
couple of very adorable tiny burgers
down the end this one is the Rodeo
Burger so we're going back to the South
for this one to make this Rodeo they've
added barbecue sauce and some onion
rings see the only reason I can think of
onion rings counting as Rodeo is that
maybe it looks a little bit like a lasso
no lasso no no and then finally we just
have a double cheeseburger you guys got
the Memphis barbecue burgers single and
double go side by side you know we in
the US we got something called the Rodeo
Burger I don't think you have that here
where it's onion rings and barbecue
sauce and surprisingly good but it's
like the smallest thing it's like that
big but this is a good idea this is that
but like adult size yeah I gotta get a
bite but I gotta make sure I get an
onion ring in it so the uh this works
really well together there's always the
creamy Mayo the Mayo and the barbecue
sauce and the onion rings and the bacon
yeah dude this is good another thing
that would do so well in the U.S I don't
know I don't have this in the states as
you say I will say they have to rename
it it have to be like the Rodeo Burger
Deluxe or something I don't know what
about this is Memphis I mean the
barbecue sauce it's a sweet sauce I
don't know what makes up memphisy
specifically and I'm still in that clear
and why onion rings equals Rodeo then
we're into some chicken fish and side
options we'll start with these ones
which are chicken fries now I'm pretty
sure we can get these or have had these
in the UK before however when we were
recording this it seems as if the only
ones available are the Doritos chili
Heatwave version whereas these are the
old-fashioned classic ones these things
are great I love these
I don't want to know how they form the
chicken into long strips like this if
British people are familiar with
refrigerators the snacks kind of like a
bigger hotter version of those it's
great next up we have a chicken sandwich
option which is the chicken Junior as
Joseph pointed out they love calling
things Junior at Burger King in the U.S
personally
I think they should be called the prince
you know
you have the Burger King as the main one
the little one should be a prince surely
he's like a chicken duke or
Archbishop of beef it just looks like a
very simple chicken burger
that's pretty good Mayo's quite like
yeah quite creamy and quite sweet
chicken Royale looks just like the
regular original chicken sandwich we got
at BK
uh longer though
oh wait but this one has cheese and
bacon
yeah this looks kind of upsetting
it's kind of a bummer okay Crispy
Chicken Memphis Style
I do like the Memphis style onion rings
and bacon and chicken with cheese that's
a that's a new combination right yeah
get out of this yeah
I think because it's fried chicken
it like adds even more like flavor to it
with the bacon cheese and onion rings
it's a bit much but it actually works
pretty well together I think we got to
Memphis up some of our uh
BK in the U.S or just just call it Rodeo
style it up then we have a fish option
the big fish it's fairly reminiscent of
like a phileo fish from McDonald's and
it's got that kind of shiny bun I do
like a good a good fish sandwich
yeah that's really not bad the fish is
like fine it doesn't taste of a turn an
acceptable attempt at a fish sandwich
probably not quite as good as a filio
fish then we have a side option we can't
find in the UK it's mozzarella sticks
I feel like yeah we have now had a point
where pretty much everywhere does it so
mozzarellastic what I will say is it
comes with a little thing of marinara
sauce which I think is the only
exclusive Source at a UK US Burger King
so we can do a very very short soft
so this is pretty strong actually
another concentrated tomato flavor it's
almost like eating a tomato puree rather
than like a marinara sauce acceptable
mozzarella sticks I probably wouldn't be
rushing to order those again plant-based
Whopper I'm pretty sure I did this in
the US right but your guys's plant-based
meat is different than ours we have the
impossible
meat in the U.S so our impossible
Whopper impossible meat has a chemical
that
is under review do you guys have a
different plant-based meat than we do so
let's see what it tastes like
it's not
bad oh my God
it's not flame grilled flavored enough
you know what I mean like the Whopper
the meat you just taste that
Grill smokiness charcoaliness whatever
you want to call it
and this it looks like they're cooked it
the same way but I'm not getting that
same flavor from this meat at all so it
still tastes like meat but don't taste
like a Whopper it doesn't have that like
Smoky flavor to it so and I don't know
that's I don't think I think they're the
meat
I think you guys gotta like Flame Grill
it more or add the same Flame Grill
chemicals onto this as you do the
regular meat this is noticeably
different than the uh than the UK
Whopper vegan chicken
this looks I mean this looks exactly
like the original chicken sandwich so
there's something weird in here
there's something weird to that flavor
I'm just gonna take a little
oh this is not a good side
because meat is not easy to pull apart
ah
that just tastes weird it doesn't taste
like chicken
it tastes like it's flavored like the
chicken but the consistency of it is
just different I don't know I wouldn't
say it was like bad it just tastes like
it's not chicken these came and went in
the U.S so fast I didn't get a chance to
try them
but now I finally do looks like a nugget
yeah it just tastes like a fake
something or other maybe bad like the
batter on this seems thicker than
regular nuggets so I'm getting almost
all batter flavor which I guess isn't
that big of a deal this doesn't taste
like chicken again it doesn't look like
it's like blank it doesn't have much
flavor to it yeah I mean I think you
guys got to step up your chemical game
because our fake meat tastes way better
and these are chili cheese bites
not clue oh no problem it's mostly ooh a
little bit of heat to them too the
jalapenos yeah these are good on to the
fries cheesy fries oh man this look this
this looks this is like really phoned in
this is really phoned in no effort on
that look at the bacon like it's not
crispy it's like right
this is the bacon you they have in an
omelette station to put in your omelette
like pre-diced or whatever but this is
like guys it's got to be crispy or
nothing come on nothing to it really
seems like a waste all right sauce talk
time got the sweet chili and the Smoky
Barbecue there's also a spicy mayo
wasn't available at the Burger King we
went to oh well it's time for sauce talk
foreign exchange
sauce talk first one sweet chili boys
sweet chili is having a moment in the UK
it's growing on me I think Switzer is
really nice Smoky Barbecue
oh this is uh in collaboration with
Bullseye steak sauce or barbecue sauce
was a big player in the sauce game a
decade or two ago but I kind of feel
like I haven't seen Bullseye in a while
um
pretty good here are all the U.S
exclusive breakfast items from Burger
King we'll start on this end what we
will find breakfast biscuit sandwiches
now if you saw the McDonald's episode
you'll know that I didn't really like
their version of a breakfast biscuit
this is the ham egg and cheese you can
also get a bacon egg and cheese or a
sausage egg and cheese now I'm still not
convinced by the notion of a breakfast
biscuit to the UK mine this kind of
looks like a scone I will say this one
kind of like feels a bit more buttery
and a bit more moist than the McDonald's
one did so maybe it won't be as bad
it's hard to tell if this is actually
like a scone or not this has more of
like a sort of bready texture than a
scone does for the British audience I
feel like a scun tends to be a bit more
crumbly and doughy whereas this one is
more pretty as for like the flavor there
is a pretty similar flavor I would say
in the sort of main taste you get is
butter I don't know it's pretty good
next up we've got the crust sandwiches
now for the uninitiated like myself this
is a breakfast sandwich but instead of a
bun or a biscuit they use a cut in half
croissant these come in the form of
bacon egg and cheese a sausage egg and
cheese a ham egg and cheese or you can
get a fully loaded option which comes
with all of the above you get the bacon
you get the ham and you get the sausage
patty coming from a country that is in
pretty close proximity to France I feel
like I do have to speak up on behalf of
my uh my French friends out there
because yeah they just look a bit sad
really I will say I kind of have more
faith in this idea than a biscuit
because at least a croissant like will
be hopefully flaky and buttery pastry
and not quite as dry as a biscuit will
be I will say there are some places in
the UK that will do like a ham and
cheese croissant
but it's usually like a full-size kind
of crescent-shaped croissant which I
would just cut in half and then add the
cheese for the ham and then toast it
um these like I don't know it's the fact
that they've got the small circular ones
so they've clearly been purpose built to
be buns I'm not really sure about that
I'll try the big boy I'll try the fully
loaded croissant which
it's actually not the worst delivery
system because it's like it is quite
thin it is quite buttery and you do get
like a little bit of the flakiness that
you'd expect as much as I kind of
disagree with the concept of a cross
sandwich if you made me choose between
one of these or a breakfast biscuit I do
think I'm choosing these because it's
closer to just like you know a sandwich
for all the croissantes you can also get
a double meat version so you can get
double meat of the bacon of the sausage
and of the ham I don't think you can get
a double fully loaded version because
that would just be kind of insane then
we have two breakfast burrito options we
have the eggnormous burrito and the
breakfast burrito Junior
if this is Junior then is this his dad
my favorite thing to do is just invent
fast food law I'm not 100 sure what's in
either of these so let's find out
oh well some sausage
oh god oh no
oh god oh oh there's like rice in it I
mean I've really made a I've made a mess
of this I'm sorry guys so I'm seeing uh
what looks like half a sausage patty
some egg
and what I think is rice
ah give it a quick quick try
that's a reasonably palatable breakfast
burrito and then the big boy the egg
normas right what do we got in here
bacon quite a lot of rice I'm not saying
any sausage in this one I'm pretty sure
it's just like egg bacon and rice let's
give it a quick try
it's okay so to me this does taste a
little bit like claggy and hard to chew
its way through
however I'm told it's supposed to come
with a salsa verde which I think they've
forgotten to give me so maybe if I had
like a salsa with it that would uh ease
the digestion a little bit also this is
called the egg enormous burrito but it's
really not very like this is not
enormous guys come on if you're gonna
call something enormous we're in America
I want properly enormous and then
finally we have some french toast sticks
what is Burger King Us's beef with
France they're really just going for
France here so I don't think I've ever
had french toast before it's not really
a thing in the UK so in the UK we have
eggy bread or egg bread which is
different with stuff eggs but it's like
a Savory things we're not putting like
vanilla and cinnamon and stuff in it I
will have like basically just egg in
bread that I will throw in a pan and
then maybe with like some ketchup I'm
being told I have to try this with the
syrup
so let's give that a go
British person tries french toast for
the first time
[Music]
I mean it is pretty good yeah
this is even more egregious than like
pancakes
because this is like it's like a churro
that you then dip in syrup somehow
that's for breakfast not convinced if
that is a breakfast food or not but it's
very tasty one last thing to know is to
add a U.S Burger King you can actually
buy several Burger options before 10 30
a.m while they're still serving the
breakfast menu they will also make you a
Whopper and I think a bacon King I'm not
really sure who wants a Whopper at like
9am there's obviously exclusive Burger
King breakfast menu items but since the
pandemic a lot of Burger Kings are still
working on a reduced menu they're almost
nowhere to be found we looked apparently
only finding them in like service
station locations so we looked around
um couldn't find a place to serve them
sorry here are some drinks that I can't
usually find in the UK we'll start with
this one which is high sea fruit punch
that's such a deeply unnatural color
DirecTV
my British palette has not adjusted to
American soft drinks yet because this
thing is aggressively sweet this one's
Dr Pepper I can't remember if this is on
the UK Burger King menu or not but I
mean I like Dr Pepper in the UK let's
see if it's the same in the US
okay and it's actually that's pretty
comparable Burger King in the US also
has some milkshake options this one is
the Oreo cookie shake this comes highly
endorsed by Joe did you say this was
your favorite fast food Shake I would
say yeah one of my favorites yeah one of
his favorites yeah High Praise let's
give it a try
I mean yeah that's delicious
that is so thick the straw like
almost isn't up to the task yeah that
really does taste like Oreos
like the filling of the Oreo and then if
that's not enough chocolate for you they
also have a chocolate Oreo cookie
milkshake I mean yeah it's basically the
same as that but I think but just with
chocolate ice cream instead of vanilla
ice cream is the base yeah I don't think
you need to mess with the formula stick
with the classic stick with vanilla okay
for drinks Brewer kings in the UK also
have tea and espresso and the one by two
didn't have hot drinks and they also
have various Capri Suns which they did
have and we did order and they forgot
them then we have some Burger King
desserts that we can't find in the UK we
have two options firstly chocolate chip
cookies seems like these come in an
order of two which have uh cemented
themselves together they don't look
brilliant they're quite uh
but like hard on the outside
I don't know if cookies are supposed to
make that noise
those are like quite over baked then we
have a slice of Hershey's Sunday pie I'm
kind of intrigued by this it's come
pretty highly recommended to me I like
the packaging this is quite fun don't
bite your nails kids
makes it very hard to open Hershey's
Sunday pies I really don't know what to
expect from this but I guess I'm just
gonna like get a scoop out and see what
happens
is it like pastry on the bottom
I can't really figure out what's going
on this I think like a sort of like a
cakey biscuit base type thing yeah that
is very rich but also very tasty
if there's one menu item that I could
keep and take back with me to the UK I'd
actually know if it would be a specific
menu item or maybe more like an
ingredient I think I would take the
bacon that you guys have at a US Burger
King and take that back to the UK
because I feel like here it actually
adds something to a burger in terms of
like texture and flavor whereas in the
UK it's just kind of there like you
don't really notice it and if there's
one menu item that I would delete from
all possible Burger King menus I think
it would be that triple Whopper I think
it just really was everything that was
wrong with American fast food in general
it's just kind of excess for the sake of
excess you don't need that much meat you
need some kind of like lubrication in
there it's just dry chewy horrible
get rid of it you've tried all of our
Burger King menu items which one are you
taking back with YouTube I think I like
the Memphis Barbecue
Burger is the best because it was like a
Rodeo Burger but it's bigger I think
more stuff on it so I think I could
really get into that
what was oh that that thick chicken the
chicken Royale specifically is the
consistency of the chicken how it tasted
it just tasted off tasted really weird
like my body was like
do not swallow spit out now so I feel
like it's a nugget version it would work
but as the chicken Royale
didn't work it's Gotta Go a Brit and an
American swap countries that try each
other's dominoes this is food Wars
we're gonna start by comparing a menu
item you can find in both the US and the
UK to see if there are subtle
differences this is a U.S large cheese
pizza this is their largest size
feels like it's a little bit bigger than
our medium in terms of visual
Impressions it looks pretty similar to a
cheese pizza that I'd find in the UK
this is the large not the extra large
and honestly it looks pretty much like
the size that I would expect from a
large pizza in the UK otherwise it looks
pretty similar in terms of the crust
obviously a lot of cheese on that you
get these little like spots where the
cheese kind of caramelizes on top yeah
pretty much like what I'm used to in the
UK
uh seems pretty close actually I can
definitely tell that this is uh
mozzarella cheese in that whatever weird
pizza cheese we have in the U.S so
um yeah this is like it's like a cleaner
taste I like this this is good give it a
try I haven't had a Domino's in ages
it's also looking like there's a pretty
high cheese to Sauce ratio on that I
feel like if you look at the kind of
cross-section
it's a lot of cheese and not a ton of
sauce
that's really not that bad I have had
some New York slices while I've been
here
and it's kind of comparable to one of
those I feel like I might offend some
New Yorkers by saying that
there's a lot of like tuts happening
around the room right now what I mean by
that is uh I think like in terms of the
way that the cheese and the sauce Blends
together there's like less of a
distinction between the cheese and the
sauce it kind of just all forms one mass
and in that regard I feel like it's
similar to a New York size there are
some differences though the crust on
this is like way less crispy than I have
come to associate with the New York
slice there's also maybe not quite as
much flavor as some of the slices that
I've tried
here's all the UK Domino's menu items I
can't get in the U.S and here are all
the Domino's menu items from the US
which you can't find in the UK
you guys have exclusive dough options
I don't know about this one guys
the double decadence you got like a
double layer
uh crust with like like a garlicky
cheese in the in the middle there here
in the UK a garlic
and Herb stuffed crust pizza this this
one also looks terrible then a crispy
crust this has to be half price or
you're getting ripped off what is this
crust
what's Italian style yeah it's like not
instant but it's still thinner
so man you guys really get specific with
the thickness of your crust we want to
dial that in huh yeah this I'd be like
in America this would be the thin crust
this would be like yeah I got that I got
the thin one right and this would be
like
people just rioting Domino's in the US
has crust options which we don't have in
the UK we'll start with this one which
is the pan crust I mean it looks pretty
good it is obviously much thicker than
the standard hand tossed slice was you
do get that kind of like pan crust
bottom there as well
I like that you get more sauce and more
distinct areas of sauce on this than the
standard slice I think often for me like
the sauce is kind of the star of the
show especially when it's a fast food
pizza
and the cheese generally doesn't have
that much flavor to it I will say I was
expecting it to be crispier on the
bottom when you see the kind of like
the cook marks on the bottom I was
expecting that to be a nice solid crust
but it is kind of squidgy not too bad
let me try a little bit of crust
slightly crisper on the edge next up
we've got the Brooklyn crust now I've
already made comparisons to New York
slices which have drawn some criticism
from the room but this is supposed to
mimic a New York slice as I now know
from a New York slice generally you're
talking low moisture mozzarella the
sauce
and that kind of mixture of like crispy
but a little bit floppy on the crust
which kind of this is doing to be honest
so it sort of looks like a New York
slice
but does it taste like one
no
it doesn't I'm sorry to uh the great
state of New York for what Domino's has
done to your pizzas
and then finally Domino's in the US does
a gluten-free base I don't know what
they've done to this gluten-free base
they've cut it so weirdly can you see
the cross sections on this I think maybe
they were trying to do it into squares
that have just completely messed up the
angle so now you get these like weird
kind of
diamond shaped slice in the middle
some like tiny triangle ones on the
sides I don't know
man right oh man no
that's bad well they've done that
yeah that's uh that's a Miss I feel like
if I were gluten-free
I think I might just skip Domino's all
right
let's go through these pizzas veggie
volcano veggies and jalapenos making it
volcanoy
let's go spice it up
nope
good
off to a good start the next veggie the
veg Aroma this one has like a lot of
seasoning on it no here we got the this
is spicy our hot and spicy not that
spicy I mean I'm seeing the jalapenos in
here that other one the volcano one was
spicier and Dory hot okay I am excited
for this I'm for real there's no
tandoori chicken pizza in the U.S yeah
that's good
that's good let's go compared to other
tandoori chicken this probably is like
uh not even remotely good but on the
pizza yeah that's a cool that's like a
that's a nice flavor profile combination
they got there yeah good on them for
that one good job so here are all the
Domino's pre-made pizzas I can get in
the U.S which you can't find in the UK
unlike a sort of visual level these look
a lot busier than I would expect a pizza
in the UK to look like these things are
topped so we'll start with this one
which is the Philly cheese steak Pizza
Philly cheese steak an iconic American
food I've never really had a proper
American Philly cheesesteak before this
is my introduction to them which I'm
sure the people of Philly will be
thrilled to hear
it's very creamy and I think the texture
of the American cheese is a bit like
claggy in the mouth I don't love the
peppers I feel like the peppers are kind
of overpowering it a lot they've been
really generous with the peppers I'm not
super generous with the steak I feel
like if you flipped the ratio of those
toppings this would be okay next up we
have the Wisconsin six cheese okay so
this is a very cheesy pizza I'm told
Wisconsin is known for its Dairy and I
suppose it's cheese production
they've actually been quite generous
with the sauce under the cheese which I
like because you need it to like cut
through all of that Dairy okay the our
veggie Supreme
oh no
corn on Pizza no
[Music]
oh God I can really taste the corn meat
delicious guys come on oh no
I'm realizing something I do not have a
taste for UK sausage
whatever we've been getting for these
shoots I think because your guy says
pork and beef but like the way you're
splicing it there's something about it I
get it why you guys would like it you
grew up eating it
we'll get well good guy hairy sausage
when it comes to us and you'll see what
I mean maybe maybe it's a different type
of sausage we just name it something
different with this
sausage you guys have is weird oh yeah
Texas I see the barbecue besides that
why else is this Texas I see chicken I
see a few sparse slices of bacon or ham
yeah all this stuff is in Texas
this does not represent the state of
Texas in any way next up we have the
Extravaganza this one I think is
probably the most chaotic in terms of
toppings what have we even got on here
I'm seeing ham
pepperoni sausage mushrooms peppers
onions and black olives and I feel like
I still might have missed some things I
feel like I'm being overloaded right now
you think you've kind of like identified
what the flavor of it is and then you
bite down on something else and then
suddenly you're tasting something
completely different next up is the
Memphis Barbecue pizza now this one has
the barbecue sauce base I believe it
does have provolone as well as
mozzarella on it which might explain
some of the extra cheesiness and then
you have some onions and the grilled
chicken
oh
I know it is a sweet barbecue sauce
technically and they are not kidding
when I say that because this is a very
very sweet
very very sweet barbecue sauce and I
think that does kind of overpower
anything else that's going on TC Mighty
meat
okay oh yeah this guy again
this has to be half price or you're
getting ripped off this thing it's a
cheeseburger pizza the cheeseburger US
Pizza I did really like
what is burger sauce is on here
yeah I like this
good
so I'm eating them on the pickles
ladies and gentlemen the absolute banger
why is it what is absolutely banging
about this okay one two
let's bring it all to the front guys
one bite
I don't know if it's really Banger next
up we have the Deluxe pizza this looks
like a slightly less chaotic version of
the Extravaganza there's still like a
lot of toppings on here but not quite so
many it's not like piled high like the
Extravaganza was see if it tastes any
less chaotic than it's uh slightly more
packed out cousin
what I'm realizing is I don't really
like peppers on Pizza I feel like it's
quite a strong flavor and when you get a
fast food pizza specifically where most
of the toppings and the cheese and the
sauce don't really offer that much in
terms of taste I feel like you have to
be quite careful with your flavor
balance and peppers are kind of throwing
that off for me next up we have the Cali
chicken bacon ranch so this one has
chicken bacon diced tomatoes I believe
our old friend provolone is back again
and of course there is ranch on this
pizza
you can see the wrench so it's basically
the ranch in lieu of tomato sauce on the
bottom I still think I just prefer
tomato sauce on a pizza I don't think I
will be swapping out my pizza sauce for
ranch anytime soon at home good Lord
guys no I'm gonna try meatball
could someone intelligent in the
comments explain if it's in U.S sausage
and meatballs and UK sausage and
meatballs it's just it's notably
different
the meteor
too much too much veggie
Sizzler
or spicy
sizzling
now this is weird to say this but is it
unfair or cheating to the market
something is being really sizzling and
spicy if all you're doing is dumping
jalapenos on it right I don't think they
did anything to like it's not like a
spicy sauce didn't add like any other
spices to it from what I can tell it's
just loaded with jalapenos which is like
well right
but a little more effort than that guys
New Yorker what
I feel like I've seen this before
no in the past five minutes
five minutes
next up is the spinach feta Pizza
I think I'll stick to my spanner
comforter instead of uh my spinach from
feta Pizza this is the buffalo chicken
pizza we have chicken onions and quite a
lot of buffalo sauce
that's barely even a pizza I don't know
if you can call that pizza oh no it's
the breakfast bricky or the brekkie oh
look what it did to the Box
mushrooms the sausage ham
tomatoes and HP Sauce
I think I think people would get this as
a novelty and then realize that the
joke's on them when it shows up here we
go with the vegan margarita
they were generous with that uh with the
herbs whatever the extra herbs they're
generous of that which is code for this
has no taste
tuna Supreme
oh God it looks like cat food tuna and
pizza is horrifying I see no Venn
diagram of enjoyment on those two
flavors two completely separate circles
I feel like every alley cat's gonna try
and like break in here through the
window oh
oh
you people are insane there's all this
whole island
Maniacs oh give me I gotta eat anything
else it's a taste in my mouth what's the
next one
I don't even care what it is
uh Chicken Feast
oh it's the corn
that's good anything else
yeah if you want to sell more Chicken
Feast pizzas just give away free tuna
pizzas
and then people are like I just taste my
mouth it's like you know it'll cost you
you got it right here yeah you're gonna
move a lot of chicken feasts
next up we have the Pacific Veggie Pizza
not sure what makes this Pacific all
right these veggies exclusive to the
Pacific as far as I can tell this
mushroom onion Olive tomato
spinach
it's okay having eaten several pizzas in
a row that contain meat in some form or
other I was quite looking forward to a
veggie one hoping it would be a bit
lighter but it kind of isn't and then
finally the last specialty pizza on the
Domino's us menu is the mitsa having
just gone from a veggie only pizza now
I'm going to a meat only Pizza this one
has bacon ham pepperoni and sausage
something about American meat
but I think it's just generally a lot
saltier than what we used to in the UK
as I was chewing that I could just feel
my mouth like drying out
I think generally my takeaway from this
section is you guys need to just calm
down slightly because this is too much
all right
we got here reduced fat cheese which
I've been told is on the UK or the UK
only Pizza no [__] you
okay I don't know what to show you I
mean it looks like cheese and then vegan
cheese this is gonna be but it comes
with its own
garlic and herb dip vegan let's see what
the vegans got going on
it tastes sour sauce options you only
get in the UK starting over here just a
straight barbecue sauce we have honey
barbecue they have regular barbecue and
then over here this monstrosity has
sun-dried tomatoes and garlic sauce they
have four exclusive meat toppings here
in the UK hot dog slices unreal chorizo
sausage sounds nice pork meatballs
tandoori chicken yeah that sounds real
good they also have two meatless meat
options vegan soya strips and vegan soya
and wheat pepperoni I think we saw that
earlier they have seven non-meat topping
options sweet corn dominoes herbs burger
sauce gherkins Heinz Ketchup HP Sauce
and garlic spread here it is the UK only
it looks like an alien Community open to
pizza place
and they were like here's that pizza you
like like this is all things humans like
and on together a lot like this like the
completely fundamental misunderstanding
of how Food Works
whoa
that was really bad
now beyond the pre-made specialty pizzas
they have some individual toppings and
customization options in the US which we
can't find in the UK so Joe has kindly
taken a bunch of the exclusive us
toppings and added them to one pizza to
create a us only
I don't even know what he's put on here
the crust looks weird I think he's gone
thin crust banana peppers spinach is
back on there
there's this looks like a meat of some
kind but I can't tell you which one
is that like beef the steak from the
Philly cheese steak the base sauce has
been swapped out for brunch of course
and the extra of that and light cheese I
mean
this thing looks like a bit of a
disaster
thin that is
what have you done ma'am oh that's bad
diamonds UK also has its own sides that
I haven't had ever so why not try them
now starting over here
potato wedges
oh yeah fries whatever
no not bad chicken strippers oh
stripping it up
I'm just okay I mean
Pizza is usually amazing so I don't know
why you get chicken strips or fries at a
pizza place
oh the nachos no
oh no UK what have you done
if you want to be a millionaire open a
decent Mexican restaurant in London
you're gonna try very hard just above
above horrible two or three steps the
line will be out the door oh my God my
soul hurts that's so terrible there went
to some exclusive U.S side options we
can't find in the UK firstly we have
tater tots now if I'm correct these are
basically balls of like mashed potato
which are then fried they can then be
topped with a range of things the ones
we've got here are Philly cheesesteak
tots
not bad they could be like slightly more
flavor going on then we have two stuffed
cheesy bread options as the name
suggests these are Big pieces of bread
topped with lots of cheese and a filling
of your choice here we have a spinach
and feta cheesy bread and then I believe
this one is bacon jalapeno cheesy bread
then we have two Twist options here we
have some garlic bread twists and
Parmesan bread twists now you don't eat
the twists on their own because they
come with dips so this is a Cheesy
marinara dip
it's basically just a bowl of their
marinara sauce with lots of melted
cheese on top I kind of see the appeal
of Dipping these in marinara sauce I
don't know if it needs the cheese that's
such Overkill
I would enjoy that way more if it was
just marinara sauce in addition to the
cheesy marinara sauce option
there's also a five cheese dip that's
just pure oil
vegan nuggets oh like this
Twisted dough balls I bet that was
better when it was hot again why are you
getting this instead of pizza
because it's the elements of pizza these
are the chicken kickers compared for
that kick
and I don't think it's common to be
honest this slaw looks a little rough
but you get a real big tub of coleslaw
we're still talking about sides but now
we're into chicken dominoes in the US
has some Wing options which we can't
find in the UK we'll start with these
ones here which are garlic parmesan
wings they have not skimped on the
garlic Palm sauce although I will say
these are tiny wings
well chicken is the skull off this is
the world's smallest chicken
maybe one of the worst Wings I've ever
had
the sauce is like a weird gloopy texture
which I really do not appreciate doesn't
even taste nice and the other Wing
option we got today was sweet mango
habanero I'll give these a quick try the
bar is pretty low after those garlic
Palm wings I have to say it's definitely
better than the other one the sauce
actually tastes kind of nice A little
bit of tweaking the method I think would
go a long way dominoes so please fix
this because these are not very good
Domino's in the US also has boneless
wings
I'm still not exactly sure what counts
as a boneless wing versus a nugget but
they're calling these boneless wings
we've got two options today which are
the crispy bacon and buffalo chicken
I'll have a quick bite of the crispy
bacon
these have been disappointing I thought
Americans did Wings better than this I'm
going to be honest there are two other
boneless wings which are a sweet
barbecue bacon and a spicy jalapeno but
we didn't get those today Domino's in
the US also offers a range of sandwiches
and pastas I don't know why because they
all look real bad I'll work my way down
this way starting with the Italian
sandwich a chicken palm and once again a
Philly cheesesteak although I feel like
if you try it to sell this in Philly
they would run you out of town there are
some other sandwiches we didn't get
today including a buffalo chicken a
chicken habanero a Mediterranean veggie
and a chicken bacon ranch then we're on
to the pasta options the ones I have in
front of me today are a chicken alfredo
and a pasta primavera I'm going to be
honest after trying all the pizzas I am
not going to try these for the sake of
my health I've heard from Joe that they
are all terrible
I think the pastas at Domino's are an
absolute Abomination and looking at them
I believe them all right it's time for
sauce talk foreign exchange
sauce talk
[Music]
garlic and herb dip
this isn't Ranch but it's pretty close
oh you have a vegan one I can taste the
difference but this one's pretty good
too honey and mustard
big honey mustard good well it's
actually really good like your sauces
are good thank you salsa okay I think
this is where we're about to fall off a
cliff here so no there's no way you got
salsa right you know what it is it's
like
there's tomato sauce here's salsa you're
you stopped like here oh Duff ranks
USA Baby all the way from Jersey
um
yep that's Frank's I know why I did that
there are four Source options in the US
which we don't have in the UK and these
are a marinara sauce a blue cheese sauce
ranch dressing and a sweet mango
habanero I will very quickly give these
all a try
it's fine the marinara sauce
is very sweet blue cheese dressing
I like a little bit of blue cheese on
wings it can be very overpowering
[Music]
oh no no it's not even that it's like
too much blue cheese it's just like
there's some kind of odd flavor in that
just tastes like slightly soured of
course we have the ranch they put this
on some of their pizzas directly
and for the real Ranch lovers you can
then also dip your crusts in it as well
I can't open this because my hands are
covered in Grease
it's quite Tangy
and last but not least the sweet mango
habanero I quite like this on the wings
I think this is like by far the best and
like most well balanced of any of these
sauces uh looks like for desserts you
guys got cookies
last one oh god what the hell is this
what do I even do with it did I cut it
let's bite right into it
listen to me
from what I can tell it's just pizza
dough with melted chocolate on it no
effort on this yeah that's weird then
the US has some dessert options which we
can't find in the UK over here we have
chocolate lava cake
okay no there is yeah there is some some
lava in there but still very gooey on
the inside
next up we have some cinnamon bread
twists so I think it's basically just
the same dough that they use for the
garlic or Parmesan bread twists but
instead of topping them with Savory
things they top them with cinnamon and
then give you some sweet icing for
dipping
this is really good
we don't have a lot of like cinnamon
roll Cinnabon type of stuff in the UK
which I think is a travesty because I
think it's really tasty
and honestly yeah these are pretty good
and the last bit by no means least
we have the marbled cookie brownie I
feel like Domino's are like surprisingly
good at desserts that's really not bad
I think overall I have to say I'm kind
of disappointed by the US Dominoes menu
I was expecting some good flavors some
good textures and various bits and Bobs
but I really didn't get much of that
honestly my main takeaway is that I
didn't like most of the menu this may be
controversial considering how much I
hate vegetables but of all the Stan like
the pizza pizzas
already like predetermined ones I was
actually very impressed with the The
Volcano veggie or veggie volcano that's
like really good that was earlier was a
little more optimistic to be honest but
I was surprised by how much I liked this
so yeah that was a good one this sounds
kind of ridiculous to say but I think if
I had to take one menu item from the US
and bring it back with me to the UK I'd
probably take the cinnamon bread twists
well I better pick one probably the one
that almost made me throw up that'd be
the tuna
horrifying
like I'm glad I know
but that was I mean it almost made me
throw up of the things on the US menu I
think the one that I would delete
permanently if I could would actually be
the Extravaganza I kind of said it at
the time but I think it's just far too
many toppings I think Joe agrees with me
on this one so I hope he doesn't push
back too hard but I think the more
toppings you add the kind of worse you
end up making a pizza there was not a
square centimeter of cheese on that
pizza it was just toppings toppings
toppings flavors were all over the place
it didn't know what pizza it was trying
to be it was just a disaster far too
much dial it back guys calm down
activity